Because inshallah you were sincere.
Allah guide you to the truth. You know,
alhamdulillah. Islam is a big lesson. We
look to Judaism connect to Judah.
Buddhism to Buddha. Christianity to
Christ. Islam not to Muhammad or Abuak.
Islam is submit yourself to God. You
know Islam is
submit yourself to Allah. with the
oneness me to pure to worship Allah
sincerely and to surrender to him for
obedience and to free yourself from
polytheism in his people because why
polytheism is the biggest crime against
God because what is justice? Justice to
put everything in its place at the right
time. Yeah.
>> So to to worship someone beside God or
to give something that belongs to God to
something or someone else other than God
that's called which is injustice.
>> Yeah.
>> Because imagine I take your rights
something belongs to you exclusively and
I give it to him.
>> That's oppression.
>> So imagine you taking something from the
creator
>> and you giving it to someone else.
Therefore you are saying to the creator
you don't deserve it. I know who should
deserve it. Yeah,
>> that's why the biggest cramp and caught
on the day all the time is when you turn
away from God and you become disbeliever
or you worship something beside God. In
the Quran, Allah said Allah forgive all
the sins
>> except one sin which is
>> when you associate partners with Allah.
>> That's why it's very important to learn
the oneness of God to give Allah his
rights. Like I said, Allah is not in
need of our worship. Allah deserves our
watch.
>> Yeah.
>> For his blessings. You know there's
example I always give about 2 million
pound. If I give you 2 million pound,
imagine I said to you, brother, I'm a
multi-millionaire. I'm going to give you
2 million pound as a gift.
>> Just a gift. If you do take it, if you
do take it, what would you say to me?
>> What would you say?
>> Thank you. Love you.
>> I love you. [laughter]
You remember me all the time.
>> I love you.
>> I like that. But I would say to you,
bro, I will give you 2 million pound on
a condition. Give me your two eyes.
>> Oh no,
>> no. See, I like straight away. No. So
your two eyes is more valuable than 2
million pound. So you understand? So why
we're not grateful to the one who gave
it to us for free? That's why there's a
narration. The prophet Muhammad said if
someone is a blind and is patient upon
it mean patient upon the trial that
Allah took his eyes, there's no reward
for him except paradise.
>> Yeah.
>> Because this this
two beloved ones,
>> you know. So like I said to you, Allah
deserves our worship. Not because in
need of our worship because he deserves
it for his blessings, for everything.
You understand? While we speaking, we
benefit from God's blessings. You
understand? You have the blink of an eye
when your eye blinks by the mercy of
God.
>> Imagine God there's people, you know,
the prophet Muhammad said, if you want
to appreciate
what you have, look at those who are
below you.
>> Go to hospitals, bro. Some people cannot
go to the bathroom by themselves. That
is a test for them cuz like this life
Allah creat
the prophet the Quran tell us why Allah
created this creation
>> for four purpose or four reasons. First
to worship God. Second as a test for us.
>> Thirdly to God to implement and to show
us his name's attributes. Yeah.
>> Likewise to recognize one another to
help one another. These are four reasons
that God created this life. You
understand? So this life is a test
brother. Allah will test you and you
becoming a Muslim and you be Islam go
Satan is going to come harder on you
now.
>> And I give you example. You know imagine
you have two opponents in the ring
>> and you're boxing with both of them. If
you knock out one of them, you're not
going to focus on the person who's on
the ground cuz it's already knocked out.
You're going to focus on the person who
standing.
>> Likewise, Satan, he does not focus on
the people who are up on his guidance
doing evil things. Where he's going to
focus on the people who are on the on
the straight path. So you accepting the
straight path, Satan is going to try to
do everything to turn you away from it.
>> Because the prophet the prophet Muhammad
said,
he said Allah's products is so valuable
and expensive and Allah's product is
paradise
>> and Allah will test us. But when you're
strong, like you said yesterday, you
want to learn more because you know
Islam is based upon knowledge.
>> You want to worship God based upon
knowledge. You don't worship God based
upon emotions.
>> You want to make sure before you do any
act of worship, you have knowledge from
the Quran or the prophetic teaching.
>> You understand, brother? But like I
said, there's there's an example or
analogies that always I give. Imagine
you have a big cake in front of you.
>> Big nice cake. If you eat all of it at
once, what will happen? You get sick.
Yeah,
>> you vomit. In order for you to feel the
sweetness of the cake, you take it bit
by bit. That's it. Now, step by step,
brother, you know, don't rush. Maybe
you're going to meet some Muslims, they
want to they want you or they expect you
to do to do everything that Yeah. That's
not Islamic teaching. No,
>> because you're a human being like me.
Even me, I have my own struggles.
>> Doesn't mean because I'm preaching, I'm
perfect. No. And in Islam, Allah,
there's a verse in the Quran said, "All
my servants,
those who have transgressed in evil
things, regardless how much evil things
you do, don't despair from Allah's
mercy." Because Allah's mercy, Allah
forgives all the sins. But we have to
repent to God, you know, don't ever give
up. You know, all of us, we are in
between. Either we for into sins or we
don't give Allah's rights correctly. So,
we always seek forgiveness. You know we
just prayed
>> after the prayer what we do soon we
finish the prayer we say I seek Allah
forgiveness I I was praying I was not
doing evil things so why I'm seeking
forgiveness because regardless how much
I would try to worship Allah you'll
never be able you will never be able to
repay back Allah for his blessings
>> you see Allah blessings even the prophet
and the messengers they will never be
able to repay back Allah for his
blessings that's why we always say, "Oh
Allah, forgive us, you know."
Alhamdulillah. My brother, may Allah
bless you, man. It's my pleasure to meet
you, bro. Inshallah, you can take my
number. Inshallah, I'll give it to uh
cuz your phone is off now. And we'll
send it to you if you have any question
or something. And if you want to come to
London, Yeah, I'm coming London.
Inshallah, come to see me, man.
Inshallah.